okay so all of you know about the
historical Senate race between brown and
Coakley Massachusetts I usually hate to
endorse any sort of political candidate
and get involved with any of that
because that's not what I do here on
this channel
but I will say that I've noticed Coakley
has been invoking the name of Ted
Kennedy so much for political gain as of
late that I just felt the need to
address Ted Kennedy that's right that's
perfect we were just talking about you
do you think you could think you'd give
an interview have you got any brandy
yeah I think we do and yes all right
stay tuned
firstly Ted thanks for sitting down with
me today of course no problem
now before we go any further Mary Jo
Kopechne me I have to ask what happened
there let me state that I did not have
sexual relations with Miss Lucy I'm
sorry I couldn't say that one with a
straight face
next question did you kill miss Kay peck
knee Wow that depends on what you are
definition of the word is it's well did
you drive off a bridge leave her in the
car and not notify anyone for eight
hours afterwards leaving her for dead in
that case yes yes I did if you want to
get technical about it right but like
the saying goes let me who has not
abandoned one of his many mistresses in
the side of the road and left up her
dead cast the first stone mr. Kennedy
how do you feel about the the recent
Senate race between Coakley and brown in
your home state that seat is rightfully
mine if that seat is taken by a
conservative then Martin Luther King jr.
will have died for nothing
what you weren't important to the
Kennedy family
you wouldn't understand these things
right well this took place in a state
which is usually give me four liberals
such as yourselves and towards the end
of the campaign Coakley seem to really
be invoking your name a lot to elicit an
emotional response how do you feel about
that well you know I'm cool with it but
that doesn't mean that I should resort
to any tricks necessary underhanded
tactics like implying that Scott Brown
is a known sex offender should not be
used doing something like insinuating
that Scott Brown has been caught
molesting a lady and her children
outside of a Dickey's Barbecue it would
be wrong and I'm not saying that people
go research that at Scott Brown as a
molester calm last question what's it
like in heaven heaven are you serious
right right right
yo meter I'm gonna fill that up for you
yeah you know I have a lot of friends
from Boston none of them talk like that
I don't know what you're talking about